sweet corn fritters and yogurt dip
it's brilliant to have a number of great
recipes up your sleeve to rely on and
let's be honest we've all got a tin of
sweetcorn somewhere so i'm going to show
you how to make the most amazing fritter
first off the mixture
take your flour sieve
really important to sieve the flour that
stops the mixture from having any lumps
in there
just before you get to the end
i want to put
half a teaspoon of baking powder the
baking powder gives the mixture some
lift
in
and just sieve that through
a touch of salt
and pepper
next an egg
about four tablespoons of milk
and give that a little whisk
now just put a little drizzle
of olive oil in there that helps to
relax the mixture
whisk that in make sure we got rid of
all those lumps
so that i want a nice smooth
almost like a cake mixture okay next
take the seeds out of a chili to lower
the heat roll the chili so give it a
really good
shake
[Music]
tap them out
slice
in half
into quarter
and each quarter
in half
and chop through
it's a really nice quick way
of slicing a chili
into the mixture spring onion
take off that outside layer of the
spring onion top and tail slice it in an
angle
it's a little bit of texture running
through the mixture i want that nice
crunch
in coriander
just slice through
nice and gently
and get that in there
next to the sweetcorn now drain it from
the tin and just pat it dry so it
doesn't make the mixture too wet
give that a nice mix
you can see now i've got two thirds
ingredients
and one third of the mixture to bind
together that's the secret of good
freighter so you're
you're biting into excitement and not
sort of dough
pan on
olive oil in
nice and hot
get a nice big dessert spoon you know
there's one nice portion
in
space the fritters evenly around the pan
in a clockwise direction so you always
know which one to turn first
just with the back of your spoon sort of
spread them out a little bit okay
palette knife
just check
and happy with the color
and turn over
beautiful
now for the chili yogurt dressing
de-seed and finely chop a red chili
and add to a pot of natural yogurt
[Music]
and then
some fresh lime
[Music]
finish with chopped coriander
coriander in
and give that a nice mix up
that chili just lifts it
the lime gives it that nice tanginess
the fritters
they smell amazing and with the sauce
tastes fantastic
that is such a delicious recipe using a
tin of sweet corn from your cupboard
amazing
it's grilled corn with chipotle chili
butter
[Music]
first the topping chopped coriander
then add softened butter
soak chipotle chilies in hot water these
are dried jalapenos which have an
amazing smoky flavor
drain and chop
[Music]
mix together and season
[Music]
next fry corn on the cob in olive oil
you want a really wonderfully charred
flavor
when coloured add water to steam through
[Music]
to eat smother the cobs in the butter
and crumble over lancashire
cheese fantastically messy to eat
grilled corn with chipotle chili butter
and utterly delicious smoky treat
this street food dish packs a wonderful
indian influence
subtly spiced chicken wrapped
grab a mortar and pestle to make a spicy
marinade for the chicken
crack open cardamom pods and add
ground ginger
coriander
cinnamon grated nutmeg
cloves of garlic
fresh coriander
lemon juice
olive oil
and season
now pulverize to form a paste
pour over the chicken thighs and leave
to marinade for up to two hours
to cook griddle on a high heat to get
wonderfully charred meat
[Music]
once the chicken is cooked warm through
tortilla wraps on the same griddle
then simply slice your chicken
and put your wrap together
top with shredded cabbage
chopped spring onion
and your favorite chilli sauce
ready in 20 minutes sticky succulent and
utterly moorish spiced chicken wrap
[Music]
you'll find my next fast food classic
all over america tasty chili dogs
[Music]
for super quick and easy beef chili
add chopped onions to hot olive oil and
cook until soft
then add chopped garlic
a teaspoon of cumin seeds and stir to
release their lovely aromatic flavour
next chili powder
turn up the heat and break beef mince
into the pan
brown and season
add tomato puree and cook through
next i'd like a spicy worcestershire
sauce
chopped in tomatoes
dried oregano
add a sprinkle of sugar
[Music]
cook frankfurter or bratwurst sausages
bung in a bun
and simply top with a spicy beef chili
[Music]
easy and irresistible a dog worth
crossing the street for
my third street food inspired recipe is
vietnamese style baguette with beef
start slicing sirloin steak into strips
then simply marinade in soy sauce the
salty
and runny honey the sweet
and leaf up to two hours
then thread your marinated bee strips
onto skewers
and pan fry in hot olive oil
for the topping which adds a lovely sour
contrast great carrot and simply leave
to pickle in rice vinegar
[Music]
next make the easy dressing simply
deseed and chop a chili
add caster sugar and lime juice
add a lug of fish sauce
slice a baguette
when lovely and brown the marinated
steak skewers are done
remove and add
top with a pickled carrot
add cool sliced cucumber
drizzle over the spicy dressing
and to finish it off add coriander
leaves
simple to make but complex in flavor
absolutely delicious
[Music]
my next easy standby supper is beef
meatball sandwich with melting
mozzarella and tomato salsa
[Music]
top a lightly toasted roll with
pan-fried meatballs then tear off chunks
of creamy buffalo mozzarella pile it on
and melt it under the grill
for the tangy salsa slice sweet red
onion then add juicy diced tomatoes and
roughly chop fresh coriander
season and drizzle with olive oil
spoon over
[Music]
perfect in a flash beef meatball
sandwich with melting mozzarella and a
tomato salsa a sandwich to die for
first up a very easy chilli and spiced
white bait
start with the spice coating
toast szechuan peppercorns and coriander
seeds in a hot dry pan to release their
flavours
[Music]
add chili flakes and grinder pestle and
water to make a fiery fine powder
combine with plain flour season and mix
add olive oil to a hot pan
coat white bait in the spicy flour mix
then fry
white bait are an oily fish that are
healthy delicious and cooking minutes
once golden they're done
fantastic with garlic mayonnaise or a
simple squeeze of lemon
[Music]
ready in under 10 minutes chilli and
spiced white bait an easy simple spicy
dish
[Music]
my next amazingly aromatic recipe is
roasted squash hummus
[Music]
start with my take on razal hanut a
classic moroccan spice blend
in a dry pan toast cinnamon cloves
coriander fenugreek and fennel seeds
then add mustard seeds and cumin
when the seeds start to pop they're
ready
add paprika and grind into a fine powder
for the hummus
peel and chop butternut squash
put on a baking tray and add garlic
simply bashed and chopped ginger
drizzle with olive oil season and
sprinkle over the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour until soft
allow to cool and place in a blender
add tahini a nutty paste made from
sesame seeds cooked chickpeas
a dash of lemon juice
and a drizzle of olive oil
blitz into a luxuriously creamy and
textured
spices toasted for maximum flavor
amazing roasted squash hummus